just 111 days ago Boris Johnson came out
of the door to number 10 and told the
nation that he was stepping down it was
the end of a long struggle to stay in
office but there were hints that for him
it wasn't over I want to thank everybody
here and
hasta la vista baby thank you
the Tories a party in desperate need of
a savior some see the man who secured
what is still a 71-seat majority as the
only hope we need someone who can come
in we need someone who can bring people
together somebody who actually has got
that mandate so a mandate from the
people at the last general election a
mandate from party members and somebody
actually who can get this party going
again get us winning elections again the
only person that I think that ticks all
those boxes is Boris Johnson
but the issues that forced him out of
office and nearly split his party still
remain the trust Premiership too short
to be fully healed I just think it's too
soon that the the I was there supporting
him to the very end but he did lose the
confidence of the majority of our
colleagues I thought that was wrong but
you have to respect that this man
believes he's the one to fix the crisis
no answer to that question this morning
his supporters suggest it could come
soon however he has made plenty of
enemies across the party but he was the
MP's favorite last time I think Rishi
with who got support from right across
the country got the most MP support last
time is a person to do that now because
we have to have that unity and also
competence and economic leadership right
at the top Penny mordant impressed at
the dispatch box just this week standing
in for Liz truss her allies say she's
the only one to unite a fractured party
right now when we are facing a couple of
international crises both in energy but
also in the Ukraine war having somebody
with stature with government experience
and who can resonate with people I think
is really important plenty of others
eyeing a run but new Chancellor Jeremy
Hunt says he's staying out
one man Loom's largest of all but
getting 100 MPS to support him is a high
bar
RIS Johnson is doing what he always does
dominating the conversation pushing
everyone else to the margins now today's
Tory leadership rules look awfully like
an attempt to stop him returning to high
office but he smashed through obstacles
before and that's why some Tory MPS want
to keep him away from the Tory
membership where he remains a firm
favorite
he divided this party as PM some now
think he can reunite them but will
enough MPS try and stop Boris Johnson
this time
Sam coat Sky News Westminster